[Music]
from karaoke joints to quirky shops to
Korean barbecue Koreatown is quickly
becoming one of LA's most popular
neighborhoods so I'm here hanging out
with this is NCT 127 Korea's new hottest
kpop my name is rich in case you didn't
know NCT 127 is a big deal not only do
they have millions of fans all over the
world they are number 2 on Billboard's
social chart that's above Ebert and
Beyonce they live together travel
together and rehearse together they even
hang out together we decided to meet to
have Korean barbecue of quarters of 6th
Avenue
[Music]
so I'm I'm originated from London and I
didn't even know what Korean barbecue
was weighted with your first time eating
it's like my third time this is pretty
much how it looks like for you as well
you can't change it much right it is
what it is Americans love cheese cheese
on everything
[Music]
there oh this is kind of like it's like
teeth oh is it I think it's called 47
choose everyone so what are we gonna
have order a large whatever you guys
want
are you guys hungry on the way the guys
ordered grilled ball Gogi pork chow
galbi B and a hundred other things so
what are all the things we got here this
is the hanky kimchi painfully vegetable
youichi it's actually alright so we try
some I'm really bad with chops that I
really bad with chopsticks so I might
need to ask for a fork oh you did this
spread thanks man
you know I'm gonna persevere I'm gonna
try it
you knew this well yeah you're just clip
them guys so what do you think is like
made kpop as big as it is because it's
just getting bigger and
but the bottle America itself is
accepting kpop more and more comfortably
now kpop meet like the NCT music is
actually really similar to pop music in
America as well it's our stuff and there
are actually American writers to write
their songs all that so I think the
listeners are more familiar with the
beats if they're if they like American
whisky as well because they always think
what's familiar to them yeah and your
fan bases and citizen
[Music]
it's not being cooked at all good yeah
just raw meat with raw egg that is a lot
that is a lot it's a joint
[Music]
next up was ice cream but bumsang milk
bar on Western Avenue not only does this
place specialize in organic ice cream
but you can customize
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so we all developer versus if she lost
and so now he was supposed to pay for
all right he's gonna do something Q
right now and if anything if it appeals
to the people who work here then it
works
[Music]
daddy daddy
[Music]
as we were enjoying our ice cream a
crowd began to form outside would you
cut out with the Panthers in terror I
took this opportunity to ask the guys
some tough questions more MORE Beyonce
[Applause]
[Music]
the next day I met them at their hotel
where they had just finished rehearsing
they were getting ready to perform at
the Hollywood Bowl these guys are famous
for their dance moves so I asked to
learn the trick or to change any then it
was off to the Hollywood Bowl on the
weight of the Hollywood Bowl they sang a
bit and then they slept a bit finally we
arrived and I was struck by how casual
and calm the whole band were they were
about to go on stage in front of a huge
audience but they just took it in their
stride needless to say they killed it
but
not charity
[Music]
he shall have the bar
[Music]
k-town is pretty awesome and so are you
NCT 127
[Music]